bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci de
m'accueillir pour parler d'une notion
pour le moins audacieuse je me suis dit
quand même ces jeunes qu'est ce qu'ils
soient audacieux aller chercher un
médecin urgentiste pour parler du
carpediem prendre le temps de vivre le
moment présent alors que dans notre
métier on serait tenté de penser qu'il
faut aller vite qu'il ya des gestes qui
sont urgents eh bien il avait tout à
fait raison car même si les gestes sont
urgents même s'il faut aller vite on une
équipe avec soin seul on ne réussit rien
seule voix peut-être plus vite mais on
en a on va moins loin la ville n'a pris
et puis finalement bélier cette équipe
et cette équipe si on est maladroit avec
on n'ira pas loin
on va se rendre compte que si on prend
le temps de vivre le moment présent on
va être capable de diminuer les émotions
négatives
être perçue comme juste bien sûr mais
surtout dans mon cachet certainement un
peu maladroit parfois verbalement
reconnaître ses maladresses tous les
jours pratiquement j'interviens dans des
entreprises et jeudi à des managers
soyez vigilants soyez attentionné
vis-à-vis de vos collaborateurs bien
jour où j'avais été un peu maladroit
avec un de mes collaborateurs le
vendredi matin
le vendredi après-midi quand ils me
croisent et me dire assez bien écrire
des bouquins mais il ya des jours où
tout pourrait en rire certaines pages
il avait raison
il avait raison et longtemps je ne
savais pas comment faire et puis un
jour je me suis dit pour trouver une
solution je pense toujours à la même
image toujours la même histoire une
image que vous avez vu sur les écrans de
télévision mesdames et messieurs le 8
juin 1972 où envoyer une petite fille
courir nu sur une route au vietnam après
un bombardement au napalm qui me choque
avait neuf ans elle dit je courais parce
que j'avais l'impression d'avoir le feu
l'intérieur de moi elle se repérer à 18
reprises de greffes de peau
et l'opérer au niveau de son cartilage
elle devient diabétique elle devient
migraineuses de manière quasi
quotidienne
en 1996 elle est invitée à intervenir
lors de l'assemblée générale des anciens
combattants de la guerre du vietnam aux
états unis et lorsqu'elle prend la
parole qui me feu que dit si l'homme qui
a lâché la bombe était dans la salle je
lui dirai monsieur il faut qu'ensemble
on bâtisse un monde de paix il y un
homme dans la salle qui fait passer un
message aux services de sécurité on le
met en relation avec kim fuck lorsqu'il
est devant kim fuck jeunes fumeurs est
en pleurs il lui dit c'est moi qui ai
lâché la bombe est ce que vous êtes en
mesure de me pardonner qui me choque le
prend dans ses bras et dit oui c'est le
passé en revanche aidez moi à bâtir un
monde de paix
quand je repense à cette histoire je
suis capable d'aller voir un
collaborateur est dur sur ce coup j'ai
pas été bon quand je prenais des gardes
on s'amuse on est capable d'aller voir
un collaborateur et du dire où j'ai été
maladroit et si on est en mesure de
reconnaître ses maladresses et bien on
va effondré
les émotions négatives et on verra dans
un instant l'intérêt défendre et les
émotions négatives
à côté de cela il faut que l'on soit
capable aussi en prenant le mode le
temps de vivre le moment présent
d'augmenter les émotions positives
j'aurais pu parler de l'autonomie pour
augmenter les émotions positives
j'aurais pu parler de la gratitude mais
je vous préfère parler de quelque chose
de très très simple d encouragement vous
savez quand on a un collègue en
difficulté sur lui dis franchement tu
t'en sors pas bien à une catastrophe
soit on va l'aider à franchir la
difficulté on va l'encourager
une étude menée au canada a montré que
si on encourage nos collaborateurs on
est en mesure de diminuer le niveau de
stress de 32% si c'est un homme de 44 %
si c'est une femme chef d'entreprise me
disais j'ai compris il le faut
encourager que les femmes non c'est
simple c'est simplement plus rentable
mais encouragé tout le monde
est bien effectivement si on encourage
les collaborateurs on va diminuer le
niveau de stress de façon significative
mais on ne va pas se contenter de cela
comme tout retour positif on va
augmenter le sentiment d'efficacité
personnelle c'est-à-dire la conscience
que dans un domaine bien précis on est
bon la confiance en soi assez globale le
sentiment d'efficacité personnelle c'est
dans un domaine bien précis si vous
encouragez vos enfants si vous
encouragez vos collaborateurs vous
augmenterez leur sentiment d'efficacité
personnelle et quand on augmente le
sentiment d'efficacité personnelle on a
plusieurs avantages on veut augmenter la
persévérance on aura des collaborateurs
des jeunes qui auront qui vont
persévérer et qu'ils réussiront mieux si
on augmente le sentiment d'efficacité
personnelle on s'est rendu compte depuis
à peu près deux ans qu'on va augmenter
la confiance en soi
mais surtout qu'on va augmenter
l'optimisme
dans notre pays vous pouvez encourager
sans problème vous ne risquez pas en
terme d' optimisme de toucher à un seuil
vous souvenez tous des résultats d'une
récente enquête à l'échelle
internationale sur 51 pays testés
dont l'afghanistan l'irak ou des pays où
la vie est facile tous les jours la
france arrive en dernière position
et c'est vrai que quand on y réfléchit
quelques secondes dans notre vie de tous
les jours qu'est ce que l'on est
pessimiste
je me souviens un jour être elle
intervenir dans une grande entreprise
j'avais passé une journée exceptionnelle
avec des managers qui avait une vraie
dimension humaine et puis le soir à 19
heures pour regagner leur port au prince
chauffeur de taxi
c'était au mois de mars 2013 la seule
vraie belle journée de mars 2013 et
soucieux de dire un mot sympathique à ce
chauffeur de taxi sans dépenser trop
d'énergie je lui à on a de la chance il
a fait un temps magnifique
là quelques mètres plus loin le seraient
aux feux tricolores il se retourne j'ai
bien vu que le message est important il
me dit oui mais il a fait trop chaud et
vous allez voir on va le payer
qu est-ce qu on est pessimiste
alain avait raison lorsqu'il disait
mieux que moi sans anecdotes le
pessimisme est d'humeur l'optimisme de
volonté oui on a toutes tous un effort
d'optimisme à faire mais l'optimisme qui
nous intéresse d'aller chercher ce n'est
pas un optimisme béat qui consisterait à
dire que tout va bien dans la pire des
situations
c'est un optimisme d'action un optimisme
compagnon de l'effort
cet optimisme là pour le définir vous
permettrait d'aller chercher une dame il
ya beaucoup compté pendant dix années de
ma vie
une femme tout à fait atypique
qui ne voyaient plus clair depuis une
quinzaine d'années quand elle avait 95
ans et qui continue à écrire des livres
elle était passionnée par la tène ancien
par la grèce antique et l'été l'académie
française c'était jacqueline de romilly
je vais voir un jour jacqueline de
romilly pour lui poser une question
sur la notion d'engagement dans la grèce
antique et on deviendra amis on se
téléphone rats tous les soirs de 21
heures à 21h30 pendant des années
et puis comme elle ne voyait pas clair
le week end c'était sa femme de ménage
qui lui préparer sa robe ses repas un
dimanche soir elle me téléphone veux
dire mon petit dr hillman arriver
aujourd'hui j'ai mis ça au four avec du
gruyère et pour la première fois de ma
vie je mangeais de la compote avec du
gruyère
elle me dit ce n'était pas bon mais si
j'avais vu clair jamais je reste plus
avoir le goût que ça avait
c'était quelqu'un d'un optimisme
remarquable je me souviens un soir
l'avoir accompagné
il participait à 93 ans une émission de
télévision à 22h j'aimerais 93 ans il ya
quand même pas d'interdît à se mettre
pour participer à des émissions de
télévision un peu tardive
en arrivant dans le hall de la maison en
question est le but sans un tapis une
chute la canne blanche d'un côté le sac
à main de l'autre elle se relève très
vite elle dit vous voyez ça commence
bien à mon âge j'ai encore les os
solides
et bien cet optimisme d'action cet
optimisme compagnon de l'effort elle l'a
fort bien résumé un jour
lorsque je la vois je lui dis mais
comment faites vous pour être toujours
aussi optimiste
elle me dit vous savez quand c'est dur
quand c'est difficile quand on voit pas
quand on ne voit pas clair qu'on est
très âgé et qu'on entend très mal c'est
difficile c'est dur tous les jours et
bien l'optimisme
c'est ce qui permet de transformer les
soucis on défie les soucis nous accable
les défis on a envie de relever
c'est ça certainement ce que nous
permettent ces petits moments du temps
présent quand on sait les utiliser parce
que n'oubliez pas qu'autour de nous pour
avancer on est une équipe et si on
augmente ses émotions positives
si on diminue les émotions négatives eh
bien on va voir qu'on a de grands
intérêts si on augmente les émotions
positives qu'on diminue les émotions
négatives on va favoriser la sécrétion
dans notre organisme que l'on soit une
femme ou un homme d'une hormone qui
s'appelle l'ocytocine
l'ocytocine une hormone qui a des effets
extrêmement intéressant d'un côté elle
va diminuer le niveau de stress et les
fondre le cortisol une hormone de stress
dans le sens de l'autre elle augmente la
générosité elle augmente l'empathie elle
favorise la cohésion
et puis enfin
on s'est rendu compte qu'elle va
améliorer nos capacités à penser la
complexité
soit dit en passant c'est la seule
hormones qui est capable à la fois de
diminuer notre niveau de stress est
d'augmenter nos capacités
intellectuelles
on a donc en nous grâce à nos
comportements des moyens extrêmement
intéressant on peut obtenir de grands
effets chez les personnes qui nous
entourent simplement grâce à nos
comportements quand on augmente les
émotions positives et qu'on diminue les
émotions négatives on va favoriser la
sécrétion d'endorphines nos morphine
naturel
là vous êtes en train de tout se
reconnaître sinon c'est vraiment que
j'allais mal dessinés à neurones à
dopamine
c'est celui ci un ca a échappé à
personne avec son neurones inhibiteur je
suis désolé c'est un tout petit peu
compliqué vous allez voir à quel point
l'espèce humaine est bien faite en temps
normal on ne sécrète pas de dopamine
l'hormone du plaisir sinon vous imaginez
sont sécrétées en permanence ça serait
impossible parce que le rhône inhibiteur
bloquent la sécrétion quand on sécrète
des endorphines
on vient bloquer stimuler les neurones
inhibiteur on le bloque le produit il
n'y ni veut plus et on va sécréter de la
dopamine l'hormone du plaisir
et le plaisir
c'est le meilleur moyen de diminuer
notre niveau de stress deux récentes
études américaines nous ont montré que
si on sait que l'on va avoir une source
de plaisir dans 72 heures est la source
de plaisir c'est pas un n + 1 c'est pas
un collègue qui vous a dit franchement
bravo pour ce que tu as fait c'est
exactement ce que j'attendais de toi
merci non si aller voir un film à
caractère humoristique dans trois jours
c'est quand même pas un plaisir colossal
et bien ce tout petit plaisir qui en
plus n'est pas immédiat va suffire pour
faire baisser le taux de cortisol dans
le sens de 40% le cortisol est une
hormone du stress ce tout petit plaisir
va suffire pour faire baisser le taux
d'adrénaline une hormone du stress que
vous connaissez tous de 70% mais comme
la nature humaine est bien fait ce tout
petit plaisir va suffire à faire
sécréter de l'hormone de croissance
l'hormone de croissance qui va venir
réparer les lésions provoquées par le
stress au niveau de notre immunité
grâce à vos comportements mesdames et
messieurs vous êtes en mesure de
diminuer les effets du stress des
personnes qui sont autour de vous vous
êtes en mesure de renforcer la cohésion
de les rendre plus créative et en même
temps de réparer d'éventuelles lésions
qui aurait été provoqué par le stress
avoué que finalement notre jeunesse
audacieuse quand elle ville faut
s'intéresser aux carpediem elle a raison
il faut que l'on prenne le temps de
vivre les moments présents
si on est en mesure de prendre le temps
de vivre le moment présent
on fera certainement émerger quelque
chose de merveilleux
on ferait émerger une nouvelle forme de
contagion
c'est certainement
la contagion de la bienveillance mais
non pas une bienveillance passive une
bienveillance active qui va rimer avec
l'exigence et qui nous permettra qui
vous permettra à mesdames et messieurs
d'aller chercher de l'excellence je vous
remercie